la foire de tour donc un lieu pour faire
des dégustations de bonnes affaires mais
où il faut également faire preuve de
réflexion avant de signer un bon de
commande car sur une fois le
consommateur ne bénéficie pas d'un droit
de rétractation on en parle plus
longuement avec notre invité du jour
Marie-Claude Fournier bonjour bonjour
vous êtes la présidente de la CLCV 37
une association de défense des
consommateurs alors comme on
l'expliquait précédemment les
particuliers n'ont normalement pas le
droit de se rétracter après un achat
fait sur une foire par contre le
professionnel lui il a des obligations
et ça passe d'abord par un panneau
d'affichage oui alors effectivement là
depuis le 1er mars 2015 doit y avoir
obligatoirement un panneau d'affichage
minimum à 3 comme format qui informe le
consommateur enfin le visiteur en
l'occurrence qu'il n'a pas le droit de
rétractation et ça doit être marqué avec
des caractères qui font une hauteur
obligatoire de 90 cm minimum donc c'est
assez gros c'est assez gros ça doit être
chaque stand sans exception est visible
le vendeur doit aussi rappeler cette
règle sur le bon de commande c'est ça
oui alors en bas du bon de commande doit
y avoir un encadré bien spécifique avec
une hauteur aussi imposée ou ça doit
être indiqué que la personne si elle
signe n'a pas droit de rétractation
alors ça c'est la règle mais comme
d'habitude il y a évidemment des
exceptions il y a deux cas particuliers
pour pouvoir résilier un achat fait sur
une fois et ça commence en cas
d'invitation expliquez-nous oui alors
par exemple bon un professionnel
invite un consommateur une personne à
venir leur trouver sur son stand et là
alors attention il faut garder
l'invitation parce que si par mégarde on
signe le bon de commande et que on veut
se rétracter après on n'a pas le droit
de rétractation mais là dans ce cas là
avec l'invitation
prouve que l'on a bien été invité et
comme on dit là dans ces cas-là c'est
considéré comme un démarchage hors
établissement et là on a le droit de
rétractation deuxième cas particulier si
on souscrit un crédit alors si l'on
souscrit un crédit effectivement pour
des articles importants je pense
par exemple une cuisine des choses comme
ça bon un camping-car
un chèque comme ça non donc on prend un
crédit et attention il faut que le
crédit soit affecté c'est-à-dire destiné
au bien pour lequel on souscrit et non
pas un crédit à la consommation parce
qu'il y a des petits malins qui
quelquefois qui vous font signer
carrément un crédit à la consommation et
là ce n'est pas un crédit affecté et là
ça ne marche pas donc il faut souscrire
un crédit et si on n'a pas ce crédit ou
même si on a des remords si finalement
on ne souhaite plus acheter le
camping-car si on a souscrit ce crédit
on peut résilier toujours dans le même
délai oui toujours dans le même délai
c'est-à-dire les 14 jours de
rétractation obligatoire un conseil il
faut se méfier des offres trop
alléchantes sur la foire oh oui quand on
voit prix foire moins 30% oh là là ça
paraît énorme vous parliez d'un
camping-car tout à l'heure un
camping-car avec moi
30%, ça représente quand même donc là
non faut rester dans le raisonnable
mettons 5% 7% à la limite prix foire
mais pas les au-delà parce que bon il y
a toujours des gens qui vous attirent ça
veut dire que quoi que le prix a été
gonflé avant avant la vente avant la
foire souvent malheureusement bon c'est
pas une majorité faut pas mettre tout le
monde non plus mais il y a toujours des
petits malins qui qui se glissent j'irai
et qui abuse quelquefois de personnes un
peu crédules quoi donc le mot d'ordre
comparé et rester vigilant c'est ça
regardez avant quand on va à la fois
quel est le prix à peu près de ce que
l'on veut acheter et puis voir si
réellement c'est un prix foire ou pas
très bien ben écoutez merci merci
Marie-Claude Fournier pour vous
expliquer